sorry what was that
look at that little girl selena gomez
and cara delevingne are performers of
many talents but one of these besties
has the upper hand i like to to come at
things with my best selena shared this
moment over the weekend explaining in
the caption let's start a trend because
why not try to make a bow with a cherry
stick we hope everybody enjoys it and
hey one out of two ain't bad
while they may not be able to bond over
this particular skill these two already
share a special connection it's amazing
you just wait
take a look at the matching ink selena
and cara got last year the watercolor
rose design is courtesy of tattoo artist
bang bang who was the first to share
selena's stunning body art to instagram
it means a couple of different things as
selena explained on live with kelly and
ryan the special meaning behind the
tattoo is more than skin deep
me and cara one of my uh best friends
i've known for i mean
i was maybe 16 when i met her and she
calls me rosebud
so it's a nickname and i've always
wanted a rose and um and now i i got one
and i love it and what's better than
working with your best friend i am so
excited in december et learned cara
joined the cast of selena's hit hulu
series only murders in the building i
think we should just hit him with the
charm good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me well i can turn on the charm
is it on now
it's just warming up the model actress
will be a series regular for the second
season playing a sophisticated art
dealer who becomes tangled in the show's
ongoing mystery and while the season
premiere is a ways out selena is sharing
fun behind-the-scenes antics like these
to tick-tock steve um
so how did you get into collecting art
yep that's the actress on set trolling
her co-stars steve martin and martin
short just check out this epic eye roll
oh that's really really interesting
because i started a very very young and
i used my eyes to look at art i didn't
know you used your eyes because of that
i thought you know you kind of felt it
and sensed it but that's just with a
live model
[Music]
you